is my great pleasure to introduce uh
we'll be presenting about fine grain
complexity uh for dynamic graph problems
so to give a little bit of background
and set up for this talk so far and all
the tutorial talks we've been talking
primarily about how to get fast
algorithms different techniques for
Designing different sorts of algorithms
um but sadly sometimes when we try to
design fast algorithms we can't always
get as efficient runtimes as we want
sometimes there are real inherent
barriers towards it and one of the
recurring themes that might occurred
some of the workshops and some of the
talks later is a variety of work that
has happened on identifying some of
these barriers and understanding the
complexity of a variety of different
problems there was a longer series of
talks on fine grain complexity in the
workshop last week but we thought it
would be a good idea to have at least
one lecture on it on this given the
different ways it could intersect our
program and to get a sense of some of
the particular work and fine-grained
complexity that might be particularly
relevant to this program
um
very kindly agreed to give a joint uh
talk on this topic to get us all up to
speed and I'll turn it over to them
thank you thank you for the introduction
so I've mentioned there were four
lectures on fanguine complexity last
week and this talk is built upon some of
these talks we would like to thank
Virginia for many of these slides
because theoretical computer scientists
who are interested in how fast you can
solve fundamental problems in the worst
case and ideally we want very efficient
algorithms right you want and say you
want linear time algorithms for many of
the problems we're interested in
the good news is that there is a huge
toolbox of algorithmic techniques to
solve these problems and many
fundamental problems can be flowed very
fast using these techniques such as Max
flow
and on the other hand there are still
problems with current the best running
time The essentially exhaustive search
because to try all possible solutions
and that's interesting to know how fast
we can beat the exhaustive search one in
time
for many fundamental problems the
current best is still essentially
exhaust exhaustive search approvals
and so these are hard problems for these
problems all known techniques techniques
get stuck and they are often important
problems from diverse areas and the
evidence for them are simple of
exhaustive search and taught in text box
and because they're exhaustive search
they are often too slow in practice
so one example hard problem is the case
type problem here we are given in
variables and a cmf formula and the
formula is the end of M causes and each
Clause is a of k literals each letter is
a variable as a negation of a variable
and we need to Output yes if there is a
Boolean assignment that satisfies this
formula and no otherwise
the exhaustive search algorithm tries or
due to the combinations of all the
assignments and runs in roughly to the
end time and the current best known
algorithm runs in future and minus c n
over K times M2 D times for some
constant C and D
and as K growth this one in time
approaches 2 to the end
so essentially as it grows there's
essentially no better than exhaustive
search algorithm
and so far no to turn to the one minus
Epsilon time algorithm is known for
positive Epsilon
another example is the longest common
subsequence problem here we are given
two strings with at most 10 characters
and let's say all the characters are
atgc
and the task is to find a subsequence of
both strings that has maximum length
and this problem has applications in
both computational biology and spell
checkers
so the textbook algorithm for it runs in
square 10 which is dynamic programming
and the current best algorithm is
slightly faster Crossing and square over
log square and time
and however we want to solve this
problem on large inputs such as human
genome and in these cases even n Square
running time even though it's polynomial
time it will still be too slow in
practice
and so far there's no N squared to the
one minus F long time algorithm known
what we would like to know why we are
getting stuck and also want to know
whether we are stuck because of the same
reason and the goal of sanguine
complexity is to explain this type of
problems questions
so here's today's plan first I will
briefly mention some traditional harness
in complexity Theory and then show how
to mimic the traditional approach in a
fine-grained way and that will be the
fun green approach
and then we will focus on Dynamic graph
problems which is one of the core topics
in this program as an example uh to show
that how to apply fanguine complexity in
some type of in this type of problem and
finally still we'll talk about some
concrete example lower bound
constructions
so
keep set we know kset is hard because
it's NP hard right and in case that we
know that if caseet has a polytime
algorithm for some Catalyst three then P
equals MP so under the widely believed
conjecture that appears not equal to MP
we can conclude that case that does not
have a polytime algorithm so this is
some conditional harness right condition
on the conjecture that P is not equal to
MP kset requires super polynomial time
and this framework can be used to show
super polynomial lower bounds
conventional lower bounds for all the
empty heart problems
how about the
the barrier is that we cannot use this
framework to show some problem which
already has polynomial runtime to be
hard so we cannot use it to show
problems such as lcis
um
to explain why LCS is hard and the other
was MP hardness is too cold screen for
our purpose
um in theoretical Community science we
often think polynomial time running time
as efficient and this is for a variety
of good reasons one who can compose two
polynomial time run polynomial time
algorithms to get another polynomial
algorithm and also the polynomial
running times are preserved even if we
change the model so
no matter what the model is turing
machine or real Random Access machine
polynomial running times will still be
put in the morning
however we will not consider into the
110 algorithm to be efficient in
practice
in the way and it's huge uh even N
squared is inefficient sometimes
theory of hardness that mimics MP
harness but we want to one necessary to
be applicable to concrete number running
times
so on the left this is uh I will show
super polynomial conditional lower Bound
for MP heart problems so let's mimic
them so first we want some hardness
hypothesis
foreign
lower bound so now we want to assume
that somehow problem H requires close to
H and 10 or input of size n and here we
also have two fixed model and let's say
we fix the model to be a random access
machine
and we want to design fine grain
reductions in order to show The
Following type of statements
we want to show that a full sound
problem Q There is a much faster than q
and time algorithm
then that will imply a much faster than
H and time algorithm for for the problem
h
and Company one and two we can conclude
that Q must require a Q and Q into the
one that's little or one time on the ram
model
Collision on the hypothesis
in the first bullet point
that will explain each of these three
aspects in more details next
so first we want some
hypotheses right so previously we
assumes set requires super important
normal time but in fact set is
contraction to be harder than that
more specifically the strong exponential
time hypothesis states that planet
Epsilon greater than zero there exists
some K such that K set on variables and
M causes cannot be solved in two to the
N times 1 minus Epsilon times poly M
time
so essentially there's no 2 to the 0.99
times n times algorithm for K set for
every trick
you can use this as our hardness
hypothesis
you know that it's much stronger than P
naught equal to MP because here the
conjecture lower bound is much higher
than super just super polynomial
besides says there are three other
commonly used hypothesis about the three
sound OB and APFT problems which I will
mention in a moment
yes with some problem we're given a set
s of n numbers and we want to answer
whether there are three numbers that sum
up to zero and it's a easy exercise to
get in square time algorithm for this
problem and the current best
running time is N squared over log
Square n
for both integer inputs and real inputs
the three sum hypothesis states that for
the three sum problems there's no
polynomially faster than Square time
algorithm
Vector problem we are given a set
s of n vectors in dimension D for some d
That's Omega log n
and all the vectors have zero one
coordinates
we want to
answer whether there are two vectors
that are orthogonal
The Brute Force algorithm runs in N
Square times d10 just by checking every
pair of vectors and current best known
upper bound is into the two minus Theta
one over log D over log n so when D is
all the log n
this running time is uh polynomarly
faster than N squared the One D is Omega
log n this becomes into two minus the
tall one so still
not bad polynomial better than N squared
so the orthogonal vector hypothesis
states that this problem requires into
two months later one time
and it's known that SAS implies this
hypothesis
and finally for the apsp problem we are
given a noduated graph and we need to
find pelvis distances
there are several classical algorithms
that run in on Cube time and current
best running time is into the n-cube
over exponential in square root login
apsp hypothesis is that this problem
requires essential and Cube time
so
uh if you believe some stress any of
says then these three hypotheses are
really are not all equivalent so if you
assume the non-detectomics take strong
exponential time hypothesis these three
are not equivalent
so we really need to work with a
different hypothesis
so now we have hypothesis uh let me
Define fun grain reduction
the intuition is the following right if
we can reduce a problem a to problem B
then we want to show that if we can
improve problem B then we can also
improve problem a
so let ABP problems and letter that
letter a and little B be there running
times
we say that is a b reducible to B
if if the following is true we can think
of the reduction as an algorithm that
has Oracle access to error code that
solves problem B
and the size Oracle code to problem B
has input size ni
uh we say ASAP reducible to B of the the
other reduction that satisfy the
following properties so first thing we
want the reduction itself so ignoring
the Oracle the running time of oracles
we want the running time of the
reduction to be a n to the one minus
Delta
um
and if the running time for each Oracle
curve is beaten to the one month's
Epsilon we want the total cost over all
these Oracle costs to also be less than
8 to the one that's Delta
if these two are true then we can
conclude that if we can solve B in b n
to the one must Epsilon term we can
solve a in a into one and still have
time
both from the
definition
and also function induction is
transitive meaning that if a is a b
reducible to B and the B is BC reducible
to C then a will be AC reducible to C
and finally I want to show some known
conditional hardness results
this given this three hypotheses so
really we can explain the difficulty of
all these wide range of problems uh just
using the
Three core hypothesis right so basically
we're actually stuck for the same
reasons several reasons
the first threesome it was traditionally
used to show a hardness of computational
geometry problems and it was also used
to show kindness of other problems such
as stream problems
and apsp for apsp is known that it's n
cubed and Cubed equivalent to a wide
range of dense graph problems so
if we can improve over the polynomial
improve over the encube running time for
any of these problems then we can
improve all of them so this is really
ideal
and finally for orthogonal Vector it's
known to imply harness of a wide range
of problems including the longest common
subsequence problem we mentioned
and for all three of these hypothesis
they are used to show hardness of
dynamic problems as well
which will
mention later
of course there are also other commonly
used hardness hypothesis and we'll also
mention some in later part of this talk
and
now let me switch Focus to Dynamic graph
problems as we have seen in Dynamic
graph problems we need to maintain a
graph under some updates either Edge
updates over text updates
and the queries out of the phone
whether swt and how many connected
components there are and so on
with also the definition of partially
Dynamic and fully dynamic in yesterday's
talk
so here's an example of a dynamic graph
algorithm that has an efficient solution
which is a dynamic connectivity problem
so here the input is an undirected graph
and we need to support Edge updates
and for each query we are given two
vertices and we need to answer whether
they are connected
algorithm foil just runs
compute the connected components after
every update of before recurring and the
current best app
data structure or update time and career
time are close to login
and there's also an unconditional lower
bound as
Omega log n so for this problem the
upper and lower bounds upper and the
lower bounds essentially match
however if we slightly change the
problem to direct the graphs
and then this problem becomes much
higher similarly so the current best
running time
is into the 1.41 per up they can correct
and for unconditional lower bounds
so the reason to improvement over the
previous log and lower bound to improve
from log into roughly log 1.5 in
but still there's exponential gap
between the upper and lower bounds
and these running times are still the
best known even if s and t are fixed
vertices
we call this a series problem
so we want to use sanguine complexity to
explain why direct irritability is much
harder than under activity
there are many more examples whose best
update and query time has exponential
gap between the best unconditional lower
bound
thank you
so the first polynomial lower Bound for
these problems on the natural hypothesis
is given by patriarchical
who showed that under the threesome
hypothesis
um
all these all the problems such as St
rich and the continent number of
points reachable from a single point and
the maintain connectivity or require
polynomial update and query time update
all query time
and this result would later improved and
extended
to more problems and also now on the
lower bound is higher it's a m to the
one third instead of M2 Alpha for some
project Alpha
um
but still the lower bound and upper
bound do not match
under the strong exponential time
hypothesis there are some matching upper
and lower bounds for for instance for
the problem of counting the number of
strongly connected components
and also for the approximate diameter
problem so now you've updating query
bound uh order of M times n essentially
after each update we have to recompute
or pressure is paths in order to solve
this problem and this m times n is
higher than om Bound for other problems
and for this there's also a matching
lower bound under fast
next I will introduce a new hypothesis
that is particularly used particularly
often in Dynamic graph problems
so this construction is about the
Boolean matrix multiplication problem
here we are given two environmental
matrices and B and we have to compute a
Biometrics Boolean Matrix C such that
the address entry of C is true if and
only if there are some K where AI can be
KJ are both true
you can use fast matrix multiplication
to solve this problem being into Omega
10.
however the issue is fast matrix
multiplication is often too slow in
practice and
so people have come up with the notion
of combinatorial algorithms that
that do not really have a formal
definition but intuitively says that uh
our these are algorithms that don't use
impractical Frameworks such as the
algebraic framework for fast metrics
multiplication
in the first test combinatorial
algorithm so far around CNN Cube over
log force and time
so still not normally faster than Cube
and the br9 hypothesis states that there
are no
until 3 minus Epsilon time combinatorial
algorithm for BMN
under bmm
there are more matching upper and lower
bounds but they only hold for
combinatorial algorithms
so far we have been using harness
contractors about static algorithms to
show hardness of dynamic problems it
will also be natural to show hardness of
dynamic problems based on hardness of
some Dynamic programs itself
so this online Matrix Vector
multiplication problem is can be viewed
as a dynamic version of the bmm problem
and in this problem we are given an
unbalanced Boolean Matrix a and
unbelievement Boolean vectors V1 to VN
given in an online order and we need to
return
a i times a times v i right after VR has
been given
so if V1 to VN are all given at once
initially then this problem is exactly
Boolean matrix multiplication but now we
have to we can only see VI plus 1 after
we have computed with a times v i
and so far the past upper Bound for this
problem is n Cube over 2 to the Omega
square target
so not quite normally faster than Cube
and the only hypothesis states that this
problem requires an essential M Cube
time
so now under the orme hypothesis
we got also got many types
lower bounds but this time unlike piano
they work against aperture or weapons
do we have any Matrix configuration like
algorithms for them that are not some
tutorials
that you get from the CMS
um
for problems that are known to be hard
on the Vietnam war that they have after
or when they're using
yeah for some problems there are
um but in general it's not not fair
because it's only a harness result and
this problem is a faster algorithm for
being another entire character over the
program
the reduction won't work but
some other other ways so for some of
them there are but for those for which
you have lower bounds under OMB you will
refute the hypothesis and we haven't
reviewed it yet so
so far now
I wonder
for the ones for which you have a bmm
reduction but not on beer yes
okay
in fact I think that people have been
using like if I probably have a VM and
lower home then it's an indication that
you might need to pass the matrix
multiplication to get a faster so
when you consider a new organ that you
can really think about how to apply
and next I will mention this very
closely related problem called oumv and
here we are given and volumetric and
then Boolean Matrix a and two and
Boolean vectors U1 V1 up to U and VN
also give that in your online fashion
now after it's query we have to return
UI transpose times a times v i
right and under the OMB hypothesis this
problem also requires essential and Cube
time and in fact for many problems known
to be o and V hard and the reduction is
actually from this oume problem
I will also mention some other variants
of omv but I will not formulate Define
them and just to show like in what
context you can you can pick what kind
of hypothesis to use
so there's this um into the envy and the
hint of the UMB problem that were used
to show hardness of dynamic Matrix
inverse and other problems and also
there's a 1v3 hypothesis that was used
used to show harness of partially
Dynamic single Source stress passes and
for both of them their contractual
running times depend on Fast matrix
multiplication or faster rectangular
matrix multiplication so if your problem
has a running time depending on Omega or
fast rectangular matrix multiplication
you might consider using these
hypothesis to show happiness
that's also there's OU nvk hypothesis
that was used to show hardness of some
Dynamic geometric problems and here are
the intuition that when the parameter K
grows this problem becomes much harder
so if you have a problem that has a
natural parameter and one that parameter
grows this problem becomes harder then
can consider using all your MDK as a
hardness hypothesis for instance such
parameter can be
the dimension in computational Geometry
problem or the edge cardinality in some
hypergraph problems
any questions
foreign
constructions
okay thanks uh so
for the rest of the talk I'll give some
concrete examples of uh using a variety
of fine-grained hypothesis to show lower
bounds for some Dynamic graph problems
so for most of these examples they
should be very simple some of them are
not simple but I'll hide the complicated
part and only show you the simple part
um
so uh first I'll show you some lower
bounds for the St reachability problem
based on two different hypotheses and
the uh the first lower bound will be
weaker and the second one will be higher
so let's
what happened
um
let's recall the definition of the
dynamic St reachability problem you have
a direct graph and have you have a fixed
Source node and fixed sync node and the
updates are edging insertions and
deletions and you want to query whether
you can go from s to T in the direct
graph
so uh first I will show a
lower bound based on either the three
song hypothesis or the apsp hypothesis
uh with a lower bound of M to the one
third where m is the number of edges in
the graph
and here instead of starting from the
hypothesis themselves I'll start from
this nice intermediate problem called
all H triangle problem so in this
problem you are given the undirected
graph G and for each Edge in the graph
you want to decide whether this Edge
belongs to one at least one of the
triangles in the graph so in this
example you have one triangle so the
answers for these three edges are yes
and the answers for the other edges are
no
okay and there is a very uh influential
paper by part rajku in 2010 which showed
a threesome lower Bound for this oh
triangle problem
the statement is that on the graph with
maximum degree root n
uh solving this oil triangle problem
requires at least quadratic time
assuming threesome so here we can easily
observe that this running time bound is
tight because the number of edges is uh
m equals n to the 1.5 because the
degrees root n and you can just for each
Edge enumerate all the root and many
neighbors to decide if this Edge belongs
to the triangle and the third time is N
squared
and you can also uh write these Bound in
terms of M which will be m to the four
thirds
okay
and so the uh this result is very useful
and most of the graph lower bounds based
on threesome are actually uh proved
using this result and more recently uh
these three sum hypothesis has been
weakened to a more believable hypothesis
called exact triangle which I won't
Define here but if you falsify this
hypothesis then you will firstify both
threesome and the apsp hypothesis
okay
so in the next slide I will uh show how
to reduce uh Azure reduction of for the
SC reachability problem and solve all
triangle using the data structure for
solving as suitability and this will
imply a threesome or apsp based lower
bounds for SD reachability
okay so the reduction is very simple so
let's say we have a oil triangle
instance and we create a dynamic St
reachability instance by creating three
vertex copies and the additionally a
fixed Source s and the fixed sync t
and uh will connect directed edges
between V1 and V2 and V2 and V3 so these
edges are just copies of the edges in
the Triangle instance but will make them
directly from left to right so
um more precisely between V1 and V2 I
will connect the edge between the copy
of U in V1 and the copy of v in V2 if
only if UV Edge
is in the original triangle instance
input graph and I'll do the same thing
for between V2 and V3
and now let's solve the oil triangle
problem for each Edge X Y we want to
decide if there exists a triangle that
contains X Y or in other words we want
to decide if there is a two path
connecting X and Y going through some
intermediate node Z
and to answer this question we can just
use our data structure SC reachability
we add edges between s and the copy of X
in V1 and then we also add an edge from
y the copy of Y in V3 to the sync node t
and because we only uh connect directed
edges from left to right so you can
easily see that uh there's uh two paths
from X to Y if and only if uh there is a
directed path from s to T in this
reachability instance so by querying
whether you can reach T from s you can
know whether x y h is inside the
triangle in the oil triangle instance
so we record the answer and then we
remove these added edges to prepare for
the next question and we repeat repeat
this for all the input edges
so we perform a
two uh
Edge update and one query for each of
the M edges so there are other M
operations in total so if we can solve
as reachability faster than one third
per operation then we would violate this
hardening results for oil triangle based
on threesome or apsp
so this is a very simple reduction but
the bound is kind of weak so
next I'll show a
lower Bound for the same problem but
based on a different hypothesis the omv
hypothesis
so this is a theorem in the paper by
hansing area at all we show that if you
can solve a series ability in less than
root M update time and less than M query
time then you would uh falsify the OU
and V hypothesis and by the equivalence
between oumb and omv hypothesis proved
in this paper you will also falsify the
omv hypothesis
okay you can compare this with the naive
algorithm that does nothing during
updates but performs a full DFS during
queries and you can see that the query
time is tied in the sense that if you
want to keep your update time unchanged
then you have you cannot improve your
query time assuming the omvi hypothesis
okay so let me show the reduction which
is also very simple so let's recall the
definition of the oumv problem you have
a fixed Boolean Matrix m
and then you receive a a bunch of vector
pairs you umv and
um
for each of the vector pairs you need to
answer new transpose times M times V
right half right after you receive this
uh Vector pair and you need to Output
the answer before you receive the next
question
and the hypothesis is that the oumv
problem requires a total time of n cubed
or in other words armotine amortized
time of N squared of uh for each uh for
each Vector pair
and here uh let's see what it means for
the answer of U transpose and V2 equal
to to be equal to one It means that they
must exist an entry in The Matrix M uh
let's say it's entry on the I throw and
Jade column it's a one and also on the
vector the ith coordinate is one in
Vector U the ith coordinates one and in
the vector v the jth coordinate is one
so the answer is one if and only if you
can find this entry i j
So based on this we can easily design a
reduction uh it's very similar to the
previous reduction we also have fixed s
and t and we have this uh a bipolar
graph in the middle connected with
direct edges from left to right and
adjacency Matrix of this by paragraph
should be equal to the Matrix m
and for each Vector pair UV
uh what you do is to you connect uh an
edge from s to I if and only if the eyes
coordinate in the vector U is equal to
one
and you do the same thing for uh the
vector v you connect edges from from the
second part to the sync node t
and you can easily observe that the
answer U transpose MV equals one if and
only if in this constructed graph you
can uh go from s to T
so by querying this St reachability uh
the instruction you can know the answer
to the umv question
and then after you know the answer you
just remove these uh added edges and
prepare for the next UV Vector pair and
let's count how many operations we need
in the introduction so for each UV
Vector pair we need to perform n Edge
updates on the left hand side and right
hand side and we we only need one and
series ability query
so this means that if we could have a
data structure that has amortized time
less than n per update and less than N
squared per query then it would uh
implied all your MB are within with a
truly sub cubic time which would falsify
the oil and we hypothesis
and because this is a dense graph so you
can also rewrite the bounds in terms of
the number of edges M so this would be a
lower bound of roughly root M Route 10
update time and M query time
okay
so on the next slide I'll show you this
simple reduction can actually be adapted
to give you a lower bounds for some
other different Dynamic graph problems
in particular the undirected shortage
path problem
so so we have just seen this reduction
that shows a lower Bound for 40 Dynamic
X reachability
but also we can use the same reduction
to show a lower Bound for the undirected
as the shortest path problem so in this
problem you have a dynamic undirected
graph and you want to query the the
distance between s and t so what do you
do you just take the same reduction and
replace all the directed edges by
undirected edges and earlier we said
that the U transpose and V equals one if
and only if you can reach T from s by
going from left to right and here you
just replace this condition by whether
the shortest distance between s and t is
equal to three
so this is because
uh
in in this graph uh the only valid uh
path is those are those uh
path from from the left to right uh that
only takes three edges and if you go
from s to T with the invalid path and it
has to have some zigzags and the
distance will be larger than three so
you can see that this is a equivalent to
whether U transpose MV equals one
so this means that you can solve the omv
question by asking the uh
the distance between s and t so this
gives you a lower Bound for this
shortage path question
and you can also go further and say that
because in this graph we only need to
distinguish whether the distance between
s and t is equal to 3 or at least five
because this is a bipartograph so so
distance 4 cannot happen because we know
s and TR on opposite sides of the
bipolar graphs so this means that we
actually show a
Five Thirds minus Delta approximation uh
version of this problem has the same
lower bound
okay so this kind of
uh
extends the this lower bound and another
way to extend these lower bound is to
show that actually uh
the incremental version of this SD
showed his path problem
also has the same lower bound and this
is a good exercise you can think about
it and I put a hint down there
and these two extensions are the all
from the hansinger at our paper
okay
um
and in particular this incremental lower
bounds matches the ES3 algorithm which
can maintain a BFS Tree in order and
amortized time in the incremental or
decremental setting
okay
um now let's look at this approximate
lower bound a natural question is to ask
whether we can show some lower bounds
for higher approximation ratio
so the problem with this simple
reduction is that if we allow a higher
approximation ratio then you can have
some zigzag paths that do not actually
correspond to a triangle but because of
your high approximation ratio they will
become false positives
so so on this slide I will briefly talk
about some very recent advances in fine
grain complexity without any proofs so
let's look at this uh K approximate
distance oracles problem so it's
slightly different from the earlier
problem in that we allow query distance
between u and v for any unb not just a
fixed source and sync and we focus on on
directed graphs so this problem has a
celebrated upper Bound by saurabh and
zwick
um you can build a distance Oracle with
2K minus 1 approximation ratio
in M times n to the 1 over K
pre-processing time and you can allow
a querying distance with this
approximation ratio in constant time
and the this distance Oracle is static
but it was later extended to decremental
setting with the slide parameter loss by
changing to 2018.
and the very recently
there is a lower bound based on the oh
triangle uh problem or you can place it
on a threesome or apsp this was by Abu
bringman hori and zamir which shows that
if you want a static K approx distance
Oracle with the sub polynomial query
time then the pre-processing time for
constructing this distance Oracle has to
take m to the one plus one over some
constant times k
so if you compare this upper bound and
lower bound you will see that the
dependency on K is right up to a
constant uh on on the exponent
um and this content was later improved
uh in stock 23 and now the uh the gap
between upper bound and lower bound is
only a two Factor so this is a very
non-trivial result and the rough idea is
that if you look at the reduction from
orange triangle to approximate shortage
path you can see that all the false
positives are those uh cycles that have
a length all your k so the idea is to
show that even in no triangle instance
with very few length order K Cycles we
can still prove that it is hard based on
threesome and then using some a kind of
techniques called cycle removal we can
establish these results
okay
okay uh so the final example I'll show
is uh uh a strong eth based lower Bound
for maintaining strongly connected
components
so in a static setting if you want to
find all the strongly connection
components in the directed graph there
is very nice algorithm that solves it in
linear time in the number of edges in a
dynamic setting if we want to maintain
the uh
as this is a with Edge insertions and
Edge Solutions
there are like two types of query that
we can consider the first type of
queries whether u and v are in the same
SCC and the second type of query is how
many secs does the current graph have
and for all the known algorithms that
can solve query one they also solve
query two although we don't know any
black box reduction between these two
kinds of queries
okay so now let's look at some previous
uh upper bounds in the partially Dynamic
setting
so assume we want a query time uh
constant time and we look at the total
update time of the algorithms in the
partially Dynamic setting in the
incremental setting there are a lot of
nice algorithms in particular in the
dense region where the number of edges
is a quadratic in N then there is this
total time n Square log and algorithm
which is amortized login and in the
sparse region uh currently the best
algorithm has m to the one third
amortized time and in the decremental
setting there is a result in with total
time M times poly log so we can see that
in the partially Dynamic setting there
are non-trivial upper bounds both for
deletion for for decremental setting and
for uh incremental setting
but in the fully Dynamic setting
we allow both insertions and deletions
and the best known solution is to just
recompute the secs after each update
and the result by Abode and vasiliska
Williams in 2014 says that indeed this
trivial rhythm is optimal under the
strong eth hypothesis
any fully Dynamic algorithm that can
support queries of the type is the
number of secs at greater than two
needs to have amortized update or query
time at least linear in m so we might as
well just recompute all the asses after
each update
Okay so
next I'll show the
reduction for proving this theorem so
we'll start from the the OV problem to
the number of SEC greater than two
queries so recall that the OV Pro in OV
problem we have n binary vectors with
very small Dimensions the dimension D is
n to the little of one or even a poly
log n and we want to decide if there are
two vectors that are orthogonal or in
other words the the chord the one
coordinates are disjoint
so
the reduction will be of the of
following template so we first have a
pre-processing stage and then for each
Vector in the input we'll have a stage
for this vector
uh the first step of this stage is to
insert D many edges
and then we'll query whether the number
of secs is greater than 2 and just based
on the answer of this query we can
decide if
this vector v is orthogonal to anyone
else and then we delete this added at
the edges and the uh repeat this for
Loop
and we can see that in total there are n
times D number of updates and they are n
queries
and the number of edges ever inserted to
the graph is at most uh
order n times D which is also almost
linear in N so this means that
if if we can have a truly sublinear time
operation then we would get the sub
quadratic algorithm for OV which will
violate strong eth
okay so so this is the plan and now
let's see how to
fill in the details so the the graph
after pre-processing will be like this
so let's parse it so we have uh two
parts on the left hand side we have a
bunch of nodes where each node encodes
one vector
and in the middle we have a smaller
number of nodes which encode the
coordinates And We additionally also
have a separate node s and another node
t
and we connect edges from the left left
part to s
and we also
um
encode the the input vectors using edges
between the left part and the middle
part
so for for each Vector U and each
coordinate C
we connect the Edge from C to U so from
right to left if and only if this the C
coordinate of the U Vector equals one
okay so so this is the definition of the
graph after the pre-processing stage
and then we start
a stage for each of the vector v and we
want to tell whether V is orthogonal to
any other vectors
and to do this
we first connect edges from s to the
nodes that encode the coordinates in the
following way we connect from s to e if
and only if the coordinate e of vector v
equals one oh
and then we also connect edges
bi-directional edges between this middle
part and the other node t
and the definition here is that
um
we connect CNT if and only if the T
coordinates or sorry the C coordinate
and of the V Vector equals zero
so basically we look at the uh the
coordinates of vector v so there are one
coordinates and zero coordinates we deal
with them separately
and we based on these coordinates we
connect these edges
and then let's uh analyze the Australian
connect components of this graph so the
first observation is that uh
there's no path from s to C if the C
coordinate of V is zero
so this is because we only connect from
s to the coordinate nodes
that are one coordinates so for zero
coordinates we don't connect the edges
so even if we go to some one coordinate
node and go to the left and then
go on some other path then then we can
only go back to S which doesn't help us
to get to a c
okay so this is the first observation
and the second observation is that
there's no path from s to T this is
because the only way to reach T is to go
through those uh
coordinate vertices that are connected
to T but these vertices are those that
have zero coordinates so again we have
no path from s to T
okay the the third observation is that
T is in an SCC with all the coordinate
seed that are zero
this easily follows from the definition
of these edges between the coordinate
nodes and T
and the next observation is that s is in
an SCC with all the coordinates C's such
that
the the secret name of V is equal to one
and
so the secs are something like this
so this is because the way we connect
edges from the accordion coordinate
nodes to the left we connect them if the
coordinates are one so if they are one
then they are connected and they are
incorporated into into this SEC that
contains s
and finally we can see that U and S are
in the same SCC if and only if there's a
coordinate C such that both U of C and V
of c are equal to 1.
or in other words if and only if u and v
are not orthogonal there are one
coordinates are overlapping
so in this way we can just uh
uh distinguish between the two scenarios
where they are just two svcs or they are
strictly more than two secs so in a case
where there are only two secs then it
must be that t is containing one SCC and
S is contained uh in another sec and
these two secs partition the whole graph
and if it's not the case then it means
that there's some
um leftover Vector nodes and these are
the nodes that are
um
are not sorry they are orthogonal to the
vectorally so by uh counting how many
secs does this graph have we can tell
whether V is orthogonal to any of the
other vectors
okay
so this finish is the description of one
stage of the reduction
and we repeat this stage for each of the
vector v and in the end we can tell
whether the entire OV instance is a yes
instance or no instance
item four yeah because you only have
ages One Direction
uh
it's technical they can skip it so this
is a cycle you can go from here to here
and here and then back to
it's not that it's just a One Direction
but that page depends on whether you or
that
coordinate is one normal well if V of C
is one
uh
s is in
um so V appears on the left as well so
you go to S to the coordinate in which B
is one and then always also
it's equivalent in in the case where
there's a single set and when there's
two seconds so here B is also on the
left
of course
in his case right when
when m is small but does this rule out
something like
no end to the 1.5 update times
that
um they are already upper bounds with m
to the one third per operation
so we kind of cannot hope to get lower
bounds higher than the universities in
Upper boundary so what is that football
let me go back
oh sorry the upper bounds are for the uh
partially dynamic
so what's your question it's your
question whether we can prove lower
bounds for
of for dense graphs yeah oh I see
um
so if you say
something like
an end for the one point
there might be matrix multiplication
based algorithms
sometimes putting this bounce in terms
of Avenue is a little misleading right
because it only works in the spaces and
when you do apricot sometimes you use n
like for example
N squared seems like the problem is
close but maybe it's not completely
close
um
Yes Virginia said in the dense regime
you can use matrix multiplication to
compute the transit closure
um
which might also help you compute SCC
matrix multiplication can help you in
the dense regime
all right
thanks for the question
okay uh yeah I think this is the end of
the talk
[Applause]
so the NCC problem it's are there two
are more than two components what have
you just asked is there a cycle or not
in the fully Dynamic scenario you know
anything about that problem
uh I think if you can solve
fully Dynamic cycle detection at least
you can solve the OS triangle problem
which has m to the one third lower bound
but I don't know if there are any higher
lower bounds than that again
slightly different but maybe related
question what happens if you're doing
batch updates
do any of these results say anything
about batch updates rather than
individuals
that is
um so all these
this one is linear already but I wonder
if you could get some kind of linear
Bound for some other problem for a batch
update situation and how many updates
would force you to
spend in your time something like that
yeah I think uh all these reductions
described here they do not distinguish
between the batch setting and the the
the real online setting because you
already know all the updates beforehand
yeah I think it's interesting to
see if we can get any like higher lower
bounds in the
in the online setting that are hiring
the badge setting I I'm not super sure
all right let's thank the speakers again
[Applause]
so that's it for the regular uh Workshop
planning for the day but Don't Stray too
far